insatiable festivaliers cette 68e
édition du festival de cannes est
décidément une année riche en première
de toutes sortes
ça fuse la dernière fois nous avons vu
comment le président du jury des longs
métrages en compétition officielle s'est
transformé en une double entité au
talent assuré est au poil soyeux et
aujourd'hui nous allons nous pencher sur
une autre création de cette édition 2015
celle du programme women in motion qui
est destiné selon le festival à mettre
en valeur la contribution des femmes au
septième art le bidule c'est découpe en
deux volets tout d'abord on a les tox
women in motion qui se dérouleront tout
au long de la compétition cannoise
il s'agit en gros de groupes de
réflexion avec un invité de prestige qui
ont pour vocation d'apporter une
perspective particulière sur la question
de la représentation des femmes dans
l'industrie du cinéma
ensuite à partir de 2016 deux prix women
in motion commenceront à être remis l'un
qui reconnaît une contribution
significative à cette représentation
féminine et l'autre qui récompense une
jeune cinéaste de talent voilà peu ou
prou pour le fonctionnement de base du
bouzin jusque là c'est clair forcément
pas tout à fait désintéressée il faut
dire que le festival de cannes a souvent
été confrontés pendant son histoire à
des accusations de sexisme ce n'est pas
un secret au sein des différentes
sélections et palmarès kahn a toujours
fait la part belle aux cinéastes
masculin
là par exemple cette année sur 19 longs
métrages en compétition officielle deux
sont réalisés par des femmes
maïwenn et valérie donzelli alors bien
sûr on dénombre plus de réalisatrice
présente dans la sélection officielle
d'autres manières comme par exemple
emmanuelle bercot en hors compétition
natalie portman en séance spéciale ou
encore naomi kawase shin soo whan ida
panananda et alice winocour dans un
certain regard
mais la compétition officielle bell a un
impact autrement plus fort la bougresse
c'est pour ça que la question des
inégalités n'est jamais aussi simple
qu'il n'y paraît il ne se résume bien
sûr pas une simple question des
statistiques prise hors contexte pour
prendre une température encore plus
précise de la situation il faut donc se
pencher en priorité sur les distinction
cannoise à la portée symbolique la plus
puissante celle qui crée le plus de
légitimité et marque les imaginaires
j'ai nommé la palme d'or et la
présidence du jury de la compétition
officielle
oui absolument voilà
et là bas le constat est encore plus
frappant sur 68 jury depuis la création
du festival de cannes en 1946 seulement
aux femmes furent présidente
olivia de havilland en 1965 sophia loren
en 1966 michel bourgat en 1971
ingrid bergman en 1973 jeanne moreau en
1975 françoise sagan 1979 encore jeanne
moreau en 1995 décidément isabelle
adjani en 1997
liv ullmann en 2001 il avait lu père en
2009 et enfin jane campion en 2014 on
sent bien dans les années 70 ils ont eu
un sursaut en mode bon les dos de son
arête de bullshit et mais globalement ça
reste peu très peu et concernant la
palme d'or là ça va aller encore plus
vite
une seule femme l'a remporté jane
campion en 1993 pour la leçon de piano
et encore avec une portée amoindri
puisqu'il a dû la partager ex-aequo avec
chen kaige et son adieu ma concubine tam
et jusqu'au bout ils l'ont pas lâché
cette palme
après bien sûr ce n'est pas exactement
la faute de l'institution cannoise sa
relève des décisions des jurys mais bon
ça mollit commencer le festival qui
adoube ces décisions alors ça revient un
petit peu au même donc jusque là le
bilan est sans appel
mais finalement quelque part est ce que
cannes et son histoire ne sont pas
simplement le reflet d'un certain état
du cinéma mondial
un cinéma mondial où la première femme à
avoir l'oscar de la meilleure
réalisation c'était kathryn bigalow en
2010 en 2000 de 10 mois sam la
coupe toujours autant mais l'avantagé
d'être le reflet du cinéma mondial c'est
de l'être aussi dans ses bons côtés et
women in motion arrive dans un contexte
où la question de la représentation des
femmes dans l'industrie du cinéma se
pose de manière renouvelée
récemment il suffit de voir le discours
prononcé par patricia arquette aux
derniers oscars et les réactions
enthousiastes qui l'a déclenchée sans
déconner j'ai cru que meryl streep
allait se mettre à faire un poirier
rotatif et pour rester dans les contrées
cannoise l'édition 2014 avait été aussi
l'occasion pour la cinéaste et
présidente du jury jane campion de
donner plus de visibilité à ces
thématiques et d'aller jusqu'à proposer
un jury entièrement composé de femmes
histoire de faire claquer une symbolique
bulldozer sur la table bref pour faire
court women motion sauf sur l'air du
temps avec une planche en titane
renforcée mais par delà les intentions
louables concrètement cette initiative
à quoi ça va servir
l'objectif se situe à long terme
parvenir à débloquer certains schémas de
pensée qui ont la vie dure
en donnant à la question de la
représentation des femmes une exposition
médiatique durable un espace réel au
sein de l'institution ainsi qu une
symbolique forte
la véritable avancée se fera lorsque le
propos de women in motion n'aura plus
simplement l'air d'une greffe
rougeoyantes mais ce sera un fusée dans
la structure même du festival est à mon
sens deux écueils sont à éviter
women in motion a beau faire partie
intégrante du programme officiel ça
n'empêche pas qu'il va falloir rester
vigilants pour que le projet ne se
transforme pas faute de résultats
immédiatement visible et une fois
l'euphorie de départ passé en une simple
vitrine de bonne conscience
l'autre point problématique qui
heureusement a été esquivée
c'est le futur prix décerné au jeune
cinéaste féminine de talent si l'autre
prix pour la contribution à la cause
féminine s'apparente plus à une sorte de
nobel cannois le prix pour les jeunes
cinéastes aurait pu poser s'il avait été
mal manier le risque d'une quasi
ghettoïsation la cause féminine à cannes
lorsque fer a pris à part c'est
considérer la catégorie que ma part est
donc jugé qu'elle ne peut pas concourir
sur les mêmes bases que les autres c'est
d'ailleurs pour ces raisons que xavier
dolan avait exprimé son rejet de la
queer palm une récompense pour les films
étiqueté lgbt que le festival lui avait
décerné pour laurence anyways en 2012
mais bon pour women in motion le système
semble différent l'heureuse élue sera
choisie directement par la lauréate du
prix de la contribution à la cause
féminine ce qui en fera plutôt une sorte
de parrainage et permettra de soutenir
un projet de la jeune cinéaste
récompensé ses frais donc le festival de
cannes a beau avoir les outils sur un
enjeu aussi délicat il va devoir
manoeuvrer avec clairvoyance mais encore
une fois women in motion arrive à ce qui
apparaît comme un moment propice à
l'évolution dans une édition cannoise où
d'ailleurs le jury des longs métrages en
compétition officielle est
harmonieusement répartis entre hommes et
femmes ou le jury de la sélection un
certain regard se trouve présidé par
isabella rossellini tandis que sa maman
ingrid bergman a été choisi comme
mascotte 2015 du festival la convergence
définir semble de bonne augure
cannes la balle est donc encore